franchement c'est j'imaginais pas la
candidate l'est républicain vient
d'apprendre qu'elle est réélu avec un
peu plus de 57 % des voix
pour marie christine dalloz de ses trois
victoires législatives
c'est de loin la plus belle j'ai
toujours douté parce que je savais que
c'était difficile parce que je voyais
une vague nationale qui qui reprit qui
s'apparente son ami tellement il y avait
et résister à ça c'est ma proximité mon
travail mon la reconnaissance de mon
investissement auprès des eaux
jurassienne d'aidé aux jurassiens de son
côté la candidate de la république en
marche avait pu espérer elle aussi la
victoire au premier tour moins de deux
points seulement la séparait de son
adversaire
de toute évidence mon électorat ne s'est
pas déplacé pour le second tour les
reports de voix qu'ils aient été
prévenus ne se sont pas faits
probablement parce que ils ont estimé
que en marche avait une trop grande
majorité au niveau national et qu'il
voulait peut-être freiné les choses le
front national s'est massivement
reportés sur madame dalloz ils se sont
mobilisés ils se sont déplacés pour
aller voter pour une candidate qui
incarne la droite dure la droite
fillonniste conservatrice et ils lui ont
donné la victoire
avec ce résultat sans appel la
circonscription de saint claude confirme
donc son ancrage à droite